il ya quelques produits j'attends avec
impatience dans l'année je me dit ça
quand il va arriver cela ça va être cool
parce que il ya toujours de jolies
promesses et un peu surprenant et le
rock phone les rock folk en tout cas le
rock food si cette année fait partie de
ce produit alors cette année je vous le
dis y'a de rothen antoine 6 ans que von
six pros et là j'ai tout un ensemble de
produits d'accessoires j'ai le nouveau
rock fun syspro que je vous présente qui
est juste là et plein de trucs pléthore
de trucs donc aujourd'hui on va regarder
ce rock food six pros on va regarder
s'il est intéressant ce qu'il vous
propose qu'est ce qu'ils proposent de 9
par rapport aux générations précédentes
quels sont les accessoires qu'est ce
qu'on peut faire avec bref c'est une
vraie console portative sur android
conte avec soin donc on y va on garde ça
vous êtes prêts c'est parti
[Musique]
la première chose à faire c'est de
regarder un petit peu l'expérience
unboxing parce que le rock falls est un
smartphone très à part alors attendez
j'en ai de tous les côtés on va mettre
les accessoires un peu de côté et on va
se concentrer dans un premier temps sur
le smartphone en lui-même le smartphone
il est dans cette boîte est en fait le
smartphone il est là on va le regarder
la première chose que j'aime et que
j'aime toujours un ici c'est une boîte
très différentes un look très à part ça
c'est hyper hyper qu'annoncé très
science fiction très honnêtement ce
qu'elle va faire astuce ici avec des
trucs complètement dingos alors regardez
ça s'ouvre comme ça tac ça vient comme
sa petite languette on le prend on tire
regardez voyez j'ai samba et ensuite ça
ça vient se lever comme ça donc je peux
pas l'emmener plus loin que ça c'est la
petite protection waouh la meule qui
bourrine de trop ok une fois que vous
arrête arriver là vous avez votre petite
carte pour venir se caler pour ensuite
vous créez votre avatar et compagnie le
smartphone est située juste là et là
vous venez enlevé et bloque donc le
smartphone est là avec à l'intérieur
l'expérience donne boxing mériterait
quand même que je fasse une vidéo pas
mais bon je vous le fais chaque fois là
je lui aussi de changer un peu la gemini
me coq hockey ensuite bloc de charge ici
la halle et ça continue a coulissé en
fait 65 watts il est fourni en usb c'est
on peut mettre de l'usbc power délivre
ici si on le souhaite donc ça c'est très
cool aussi bien évidemment le petit
câble qui fournit avec pour venir le
charger très facilement et voilà c'est
cool comme ça on à la complète on est
bien c'est mignon c'est sympa on peut
prendre pour poser enfin on va remettre
ça quand même parce que ça fait partie
de ce peuple a de l'expérience
on prend on remet en forme ça c'est pour
le smartphone en lui même ensuite avec
vous avez des tonnes d'accessoires
accessoires numéro un ça va être l'aéro
active couleur ça en fait le petit
ventilateur le gros ventilateur que vous
avez avec qu'il ya des nouveautés cette
année c'est celui là en fait qui vient
se poser au dos de votre smartphone
alors je vous montre regardez juste ici
là j'ai un petit bouton j'appuie ça me
lève je prends mon smartphone nouveautés
on va tout de suite déjà ici vous avez
plus qu un port usb c'est alors qu'avant
vous avez un port propriétaire vous
prenez vous le posez tac comme ça vous
venez vous clipser vous avez déjà petits
boutons sur le dessus qui va servir à
venir à allumer votre téléphone qui
marche le petit bouton aussi qui
servirait à venir à l'éjecter et puis
surtout alors vous allez ça qui est
sympa on évitait tout arraché comme moi
ça vous fait un petit stand en fait pour
venir me poser comme ça si vous voulez
utilisant c'est une manette je vais vous
montrer ça vous l'avez face à vous à ces
pratiques sinon vous voulez leur ferme
et surtout vous avez quatre boutons à
l'arrière un ici un ici un ici un ici
donc là lorsque vous jouez en termes de
prise en main comme ça vous l'avez vous
avez vos petits boutons en plus des
voleurs trigger sur le dessus enfin bref
l'expérience est quand même vachement
coût en terme de gaming bon ça c'est
chouette donc ça c'est pour la grotte
kif couleurs avec différents modes je
vous le montrerai tout à l'heure en
détail up premier accessoire autres
accessoires que vous allez avoir eh bien
c'est le kunai game pad qui est juste là
alors ça c'est pareil ça c'est vachement
cool parce qu'on n'est pas une solution
soit vous avez vos petits gamepad qu'il
prenait vous les enlevez voilà vous mais
glissé sur le haut soit vous venez les
raccorder directement avec la partie
centrale ici et cela pourrait prendre
votre smartphone vous le mettez sur
l'aéronautique couleurs hop là où le
poser en face de vous et là vous jouez
directement avec vos boutons sur le
dessus vous avez quatre boutons ici vous
avez tous les boutons en façade là et
vous avez encore deux boutons derrière
donc ça c'est plutôt cool vous pouvez
l'utiliser comme ça vous pouvez
également venir le m ici la garde et hop
voilà il vient se poser là pour avoir
une meilleure prise en main donc on peut
le mettre là dessus mais ça ne s'arrête
pas là le petit bouton dessus l'aop la
légère vous pouvez reprendre votre
smartphone
étaient ou sans tout casser voulant
voter directement ici hop là vous le
prenez vous le clip c'est vous sortez ça
et ça vous fait comme une console alors
ça c'est pas nouveau on l'avait déjà les
dernières nouveautés que vous avez ici
c'est qu'en fait il est blanc alors
qu'avant ils étaient voir donc là vous
l'avez en blanc et vous utilisez votre
rock 26 comme une console qu'un peu
comme une nintendo switch en termes de
prise en main et de forme donc ça c'est
très cool et puis bien évidemment pour
rien transportez vous avez le petit étui
qui est ici avec ont déjà voyez que en
termes d'accessoires d'options de
possibilités c'est les options fournir
les achats en plus on a ce qu'il faut
vous avez ensuite ici une coque c'est là
des villes qu'elle souhaitait pouvoir me
retrouver en face c'est plutôt sympa bon
je l'ait pas misé mois et vous avez
ensuite une protection d'écran pour
mettre à la vente de smartphones autant
vous dire qu'ici en termes d'accessoires
vous avez vraiment ce qu'il faut ça vous
permet d'avoir une expérience un peu à
360° avec le smartphone pour unir le
rafraîchir pour venir avoir des boutons
de tous les côtés et puis starhawk folie
à dr fricker star des petites touches
ici physique enfin qu'on ne voit pas
mais en fait sont réellement des touches
où il ya de nouvelles actions sur l'ir
trigger et s'en va le regard est aussi
le design c'est un élément extrêmement
important qu'on va retrouver ici sur son
rock phone alors sur iphone syspro vous
avez un truc est tout nouveau c'est que
vous avez ça ce texte un petit écran en
fait avec différentes animations dont
vos fonctions vous allez venir recharger
votre smartphone que vous allez jouer
vous allez avoir une animation qui va
être différente et lorsque vous venez
vous voyez que vous lancez un jeu rd je
vous montre on va ici dans un mot rick
wright et on va se lancer un jeu j'en
serais moins pub jmobil par exemple eh
bien regardez vous avez ça qui s'allume
en haut où il ya écrit deere to play
donc lorsque vous jouez ses écrits si on
revenait pas me déranger suis en train
de jouer avec le petit écran gamestar
qui est justement il en use est en train
de jouer que vous allez jouer donc ça
c'est très chouette et ça va
complètement se personnaliser ce truc là
alors nous on va sentir objets mobiles
tout ça on l'a dans armorique wright
j'en ferai un petit tour tout à l'heure
comme ça je vous montrerai tout donc
déjà ça c'est vachement bien en termes
de design d'avoir ces écrans on a
effectivement aussi des caméras on
reviendra dans quelques instants ici
donc ça c'est très cool un design qui a
une fois de plus très bien réussi très
jolie un très grand smartphone attention
si c'est pas un petit smartphone on se
parle vraiment d'un très grand
smartphone très long avec une caméra de
saïfi qui est planqué sur le haut juste
là mais comme on se met sur des dark
thème ça ne nous dérange pas puisque je
vous parle de thèmes vous avez des
tonnes de thèmes vous venez également
dans vos paramètres thèmes et fonds
d'écran boutique de thèmes il ya pas mal
de partenariat ici partenariat avec paul
j fan à plusieurs où vous avez pas mal
de thèmes gratos ça c'est très cool
alors chicken police je vous montre up
la chicane police y en a pas mal walking
dead après à vous de voir devenir
trouver votre bonheur ici moi j'ai me
suis là je trouve très très canon enfin
il y en a plein bref donc à vous de
venir voir voir ce qui vous intéresse
doomsday aussi c'est très très cool en
bas j'aime beaucoup et l inde est
gratuit j'en ai les payant il y en a
pour tous les goûts donc ça c'est sans
le modèle professionnel c'est l'écran
révision si vous êtes uniquement sur le
6 vous aurez des led rgb qui vont venir
s'allumer qui vont être sympa on n'ira
pas aussi loin mais c'est pas non plus
même près tout en sachant est un autre
point qui est intéressant je voulais
montrer on a plus de port propriétaire
ici ici ce que vous avez c'est une prise
en usb s'époumone à brancher le
ventilateur pwm et venir recharger
directement par ici si vous voulez avoir
une sortie hdmi pour brancher sur une
télé ce qui est aussi très cool comme ça
vous le prenez vous mettez sur la télé
et vous vous jouez avec votre manette
vous êtes penhars assez chouette aussi
et puisque je vous parle de rock vision
l'écran que vous avez derrière garder
ici dans un mot rick wright vous venez
et vous pouvez voir ce qu'il en ira tout
de suite je veux que j'ai ça et si je
clique alors ça regardez écran allumé
j'ai ça hop la batterie en charge ça va
mettre ça donc je le prends je charge le
merlan verts genevois où j'en suis au
niveau de ma charge lorsque je joue un
jeu c'est le game start qui apparaît un
appel entrant aux places mais que
j'appelle ça aussi c'est plutôt cool
donc c'est vachement intéressant donc ça
on l'a vu me dis que c'est le mode
performance ce que vous jouez
accessoires externe on peut aussi bien
le retrouver donc je trouve ça très très
cool et en cliquant dessus après voyez
on en a d'autres donc vous en avez
énormément d'animation on peut bien
mettre ce qu'on veut en fonction de ce
qu'il vous plaît tiens on va se mettre
par exemple celui là hop là j'applique
la il activé et voyez j'ai retrouvé mon
animation ici derrière donc c'est très
chouette n'ont qu'à plein plein plein
d'animations en fonction de ce que vous
voulez on peut venir personnalisé c'est
vraiment une superbe expérience de
guenilles qu'on a ici j'envoie des
smartphones passé en terme d'expérience
smartphones de gaming on a ici une
expérience qui est extrêmement complète
si vous aviez meurt il y fait son petit
point on est dans les deux sens et
quelques grammes sur ce smartphone j'ai
pas le poids exact mais vous assurer qu
on soupèse quand même pas mal autre truc
qui est intéressant et on le voit c'est
un très grand écran diagonale de 6 60 18
pouces c'est très grand c'est une dalle
samsung c'est une dalle amoled et on a
surtout un taux de rafraîchissement de
165 hertz c'est énorme et alors ça je
peux vous le dire directement je suis
venu jouer à des jeux lorsque je les
prie en main lorsque je les utilise et
lorsque j'ai commencé à jouer j'ai dit
ah ouais quand même pas dégueulasse
parce que c'est très réactif et on a pu
s'en taux d'échantillonnage tactile de 7
120 hertz entend de vous dire que
lorsque vous jouez c'est extrêmement
réactif à regarder le mieux en taux de
rafraîchissement automatique mais on
peut le mettre comme on veut 60 hertz 90
120 140 465 c'est extrêmement rapide
alors attention plus on en met plus on
consomme mais lorsque vous jouez vous
voulez c'est automatique il va choisir
par lui-même c'est juste hyper démentiel
est super cool et je n'en crois tout à
l'heure lors d'un jeu alors ici je vous
passe un peu l'histoire on est en fonte
% d'essayer p3 on a un deltae inférieur
un gain évidemment et on a un corning
gorilla glass victime ici à la vente de
smartphones puisque on se parle ici d'un
smartphone de gaming on se parle de
performances on se parle de beaucoup de
performances avec la puce la plus
puissante du moment c'est le snapdragon
8 + jane 1 alors ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire qu'en fait je vous ai présenté
les dernières séquences qui au mois de
décembre je vais présenter sa dragonne 8
jane indirectement j'étais à hawaï avec
qualcomm ça c'est la nouvelle version
c'est un peu de la 2me générations qui
viennent proposer avec une version si tu
as dragon 8 + jane 1 l intérêt ici et y
en a plusieurs déjà c'est que une petite
différence de gravure le stand dragon 8
jane 1 était grave est d'ailleurs
toujours gravé par samsung le 8 plus est
gravé par tsmc a priori la version plus
grave et partez sncf chaufferie moins
que l'autre modèle de sa dragonne huit
jeunes ont donc ça va être vraiment
intéressante donc ça veut dire qu'on
aurait effectivement un processeur qui
chaufferie mois s'écoulent on a bien
évidemment plus de performances au
niveau cpu haut niveau chez péaule aussi
meilleure gestion de l'autonomie
fatalement pour la performance est aussi
un truc est vachement bien que nous fait
ici asus et bien c'est le mode x alors
le mode x on a plusieurs moyens pour
venir le lancer modique cela regardez
vous appuyer la taxe vous activer et
vous lancez le modique somme le marquant
aussi là j'ai un petit icône x ça veut
dire que j'aime modique de lancer alors
le mode xp aussi le paramétrer depuis un
mot rick wright un brick lane je le
récupère ici et là voyez hop là dans mon
interface mode x directement alors j'ai
plusieurs mode mais sans aucun doute à
l'heure en titre dans la thermos rick
wright le modique celui qui va tartiner
à fond qui va aller le plus loin et ça
c'est très cool tout en sachant qu'ici
alors c'est pas le modique somme il ya
un autre truc qui est intéressant c'est
qu'il ya une amélioration du moteur à
petit pour tout ce qu'il a eu de
libration optique donc ça c'est cool
autre point qui est extrêmement
important lorsqu'on joue un jeu lens
qu'on jouerait quand smartphone un
moment il va venir chauffer et pour
éviter qu'elles chauffent il ya
plusieurs choses qui ont été mis en
place ici directement par asus la
première c'est la présence de
ventilateur c'est pas tout nouveau
l'aéronautique couleurs mais ce qui est
intéressant ici c'est qu'effectivement
il ya plusieurs modes de refroidissement
alors ça je vous le monde regardez déjà
il ya un vrai bénéfice au moment où je
en train de tourner cette vidéo on est
en plein été on aura pleine période de
canicule il fait très chaud lorsque je
branche le ventilateur que je mets la
main derrière je sens un petit peu d'air
frais c'est l'extraction ça c'est cool
ça me marque la température à la voyait
directement aux places à l'enlever donc
assez cool les ressorts par là en fait
voyez quand je viens ici de la même
manière je viens tag directement dans
amérique waits et je vais ici et là
regardez je vais avoir mon héros actifs
couleurs qui est présentée juste ici
avec la température plus de paramètres
j'ai différents modes en fait je vais
avoir un mode intelligent qui va venir
extraire en fonction de la température
interne de votre smartphone savoir un
mode frais qui va venir tartiner
davantage sa extrait davantage sa
souffre encore plus haut là ça va au max
et alors là j'en ai un qui n'est pas
activé tout de suite et vous pouvez voir
c'est le mode je l'aimé pour venir
l'activer il faut que je le branche
directement sur le secteur parce que là
pour le coup ça ça turbine au max mais
ça va venir refroidir directement et
alors attendez j'ai le nombre de degrés
perdu ça c'est vachement intéressant
lorsque je suis en mode frais je vais
perdre 4 degrés lorsque je suis en mode
glacial en fait là le mode frais c'est
uniquement les pannes mécaniques qui
vont tourner le mode glacial c'est un
mélange à la fois des pannes mécaniques
et en même temps de l'élément pelletier
on en parle dans quelques instants et
lorsque je passe en mode gelé pour celui
qui est là l'équipe a qu'il est tout de
suite et bien là j'ai moins huit degrés
et ça me permet effectivement de
diminuer fortement la température donc
voyez ça c'est sympa ça se faire
directement ici et on retrouve tous dans
la mort écrit donc ça c'est aussi très
très chouette alors au delà des boutons
faisons tout à l'heure ce petit ventilo
il est quand même extrêmement pratique
mais il n'ya pas que le ventilo qui est
pratiqué qui vous servira directement
baisser la température des smartphones
vous avez aussi des feuilles de grafite
à l'intérieur qui sont 85% plus grande
que la génération précédente autre truc
c'est que votre processeur votre stock
il est mis au centre donc le fait de
l'avoir repositionné au centre sava et
venir évitez d'avoir de la chauffe ici
ça va venir optimiser la dissipation
thermique autre truc qui est intéressant
c'est que vous avez une double batterie
qui vient permettre aussi de diffuser
davantage la chaleur émise par les
batteries des smartphones vous avez une
chambre à vapeur qui élargit de 30 % et
vous avez un élément pelletier l'élément
pelletier fait quoi il prend la charge
d'un côté et il l'envoie de l'autre côté
comme ça on décide tout en sachant que
vous avez également un capteur
d'humidité qui permettra de venir lutter
contre la condensation hanquet
l'humidité donc ici vous avez un
smartphone un peu tout en un qui aurait
m'en servir à venir évitez la chauffe
soit directement l'huile à ce qu'il faut
à l'intérieur soit en ont rajouté ce
petit ventilateur là tout en sachant
qu'ici vous allez certification ip ce 4
alors c'est pas une libération de suite
c'est quand même bien outre les
éclaboussures et c'est plutôt rare pour
ce genre de smartphones d'avoir ici une
certification contre les éclaboussures
alors ça c'est bien le jeu le gaming
c'est cool mais il ya un autre truc est
extrêmement important dans l'expérience
de gaming mais pas que celle audio et ça
c'est vachement bien parce que c'est un
de mes smartphone préféré au niveau de
l'audio je vous fait écouter regarder je
vous mets ici on va avancer regardez
déjà on a beaucoup de sons et en plus de
ça vous avez une vraie symétrie au
niveau des hauts parleurs ce qui fait
que on y est ceci mes tripes c'est
vachement bien ils sont planqués ici et
ici alors gardez vos haut-parleurs ici
deuxième haut parleurs ici et ça ça nous
apporte quoi ça vous apporte vraiment en
immersion lorsque vous voulez juin
jusqu'au bien regarder un film une série
on a une expérience audio qui vraiment
de bonne qualité mais ça ne s'arrête pas
là parce que chez asus eee sommes pas
faire les choses à moitié vous venez là
on switch son côté et vous avez ici
l'assistant audio alors l'assistant
violet très cool ça vous donne un peu la
main sur tous vos paramètres alors on le
voit ici il bosse toujours avec d'irak
vous avez des effets de scénario
dynamique musique cinéma jeux ça dépend
de ce que vous allez faire bien
évidemment qu'après vous avez un
équaliseur multibandes alors les
coalisés multibandes c'est vachement
bien lorsque vous venez écouter
également et adapté totalement ça
peut-être plus intéressant ici avec un
casque peut le faire directement il ya
plein d'options c'est très cool et une
très bonne gestion je trouve vraiment
intéressante et si en plus de ça vous
avez elle est juste en dessous la petite
prise jack et préservés dont pouvait
venir branché ici un casque très
facilement vous avez en plus du coin
comme à péter x adaptative à ptx
loseless est du reste donc en termes
d'audio vous avez aussi un truc est
extrêmement complet donc ça c'est un
truc qui est chouette aussi parce que
souvent on pense smartphones de gaming
et on se dit ok c'est très bien pour
venir jouer il ya de la performance il
ya des choses qui sont laissés de côté
ici ce smartphone qui est très complet
alors attention sera pas destiné à tout
le monde parce que très typé parce que
aussi un peu lourd fatalement vu tout ce
qu'on a à l'intérieur mais ils n'ont pas
laissé des choses de côté l'audio n'est
pas le parent pauvre le fait d'avoir les
deux haut parleurs de la même taille ça
apporte vraiment et ça surtout que j'ai
souvent reproché à beaucoup de
smartphones qui n'ont pas à des haut
parleurs de la même taille ce qui fait
qu'on a une asymétrie audio et là c'est
pas le cas donc ça c'est bien autre truc
qui est intéressant alors là vous le
verrez pas s'arrêter ailleurs on va
avoir une très gros batterie de 6000
millan père heures pour venir jouer
longtemps alors attention joué longtemps
oui et non ça dépend de vous ça dépend
du mode dans lequel vous allez venir
vous mettre ça dépend si vous allez
faire tourner les performances à fond la
caisse vous êtes en 165 r ça dépend de
plein de choses mais après il ya des
modes qui sont aussi intéressants au
niveau de la recharge un truc que fait
ici asus qui est très cool c'est que
lorsque vous venez prendre votre
smartphone et que vous le jouez branché
et bien vous avez un mode qui va venir
bypass et la charge ce qui fait qu'on va
utiliser l'énergie du secteur qui va
rentrer dans votre smartphone mais qui
ne va pas passer par votre batterie ça
servir uniquement alimenté le smartphone
donc ça pas venir dégrader la durée de
vie de votre smartphone ça c'est
chouette et pour une charge complète
issifou comptable près une quarantaine
de minutes 42 minutes nous dit asus
autres sujets intéressants et je vous le
montre depuis tout à l'heure c'est
armorique right now revenir faire un
petit tour si vous ne connaissez pas un
mot rick wright c'est l'expérience
gaming le moteur du gaming enroulé de
software de asus vous appuyez dessus et
on rentre dedans alors il ya plusieurs
choses à connaître ici première chose
vous allez voir votre bibliothèque de
jeux avec tous vos jeux vous venez
choisir directement là j'en ai quelques
uns ici on va se prendre un peu le gie
avec par exemple des profils de scénario
vous pouvez vous dire lorsque je lance
poggi moi je veux être en mode x en
haute dynamique en mode ultra durable et
des jeux qui vont pas nécessité d'avoir
un mode xp ji hong le hockey peut venir
à lormont mappage de touche bouton à
ultrasons gauche appuyée droite appuyée
contrôle des mouvements inclinée vers la
droite inclinée vers la gauche c'est
aussi un mouvement payeur je recharge
clac clac et les boutons couleurs
moelleuse et paramétrer directement
depuis le jeu où je vous montrais ça
dans quelques instants mais voyez ça
c'est vachement chez parce que je peux
venir à l'est par exemple plus mais ça
et un asphalte 9 par exemple hop là
scénario en mode dynamique samira bien
j'ai pas besoin ici devient maître un
mode x mais ensuite j'ai les
enregistrements brossard on s'en fiche
un petit peu donc ça c'est le premier
truc qui est très très cool ensuite ici
je vais avoir un peu toutes les infos au
niveau de long or die au niveau de mon
cpu au niveau de mon gpu par la
température l'espace utilisé la mémoire
utilisée c'est un peu une carte du mode
x le mode dynamique ultra durable en
suisse différentes visions je vous ai
montré que je peux venir paramétrer à
derrière l'éclairage du système que je
peux venir activer désactiver cette
petit bouton envoyer dr tout plein mon
iront-ils couleurs ici et mon mode génie
du jeu que je peux venir ensuite
personnaliser aller dans les préférences
au niveau de mes airs trigger ici voyez
là j'ai pas mal de petites possibilités
au niveau de mes airs trigger paramètres
d'inclinaison de l'avant à qui livre à
l'arrière paramètres incliné à droite et
compagnie donc je peux aller très très
loin et c'est ça qui est très très cool
ici ensuite ici bon ses côtés réseau
social mais je dirais qu'on s'en fiche
un petit peu ici j'ai retrouvé les jeux
alors c'est intéressant parce que je
vois les gens en fonction du nombre de
hertz 165 m j'ai déjà 144 hertz des
géants 120 hertz bon ok on peut passer
très très rapidement et puis ensuite je
vais avoir mon profil directement ici et
quelques infos donc ici on vient peut
paramétrer et avoir toutes les infos au
niveau de la party gaming mais pas que
gaming ici donc ça c'est très très
chouette et après je vais vous montrer
un jeu on va se mettre quoi par exemple
allez on va se mettre un petit meuble
immobile moi je me suis fait un autre
truc regardez pas ce que je vais appuyer
deux fois ici ça me fait une capture
d'écran ça c'est un côté un peu pratique
je viens ici et j'ai mon game genie mon
génie du japon il arrivait sur le côté
et maintenant ils arrivent par en bas
c'est une demande cependant aux
utilisateurs d'en face a plutôt bien
taux de rafraîchissement je suis en 144
hertz informations en temps réel je veux
que je suis en x mode mert rigueur
verrouillage macro donc j'ai accès à
tous directement ici c'est vachement
pratique très sympa ce tout petit
changement elle fait de la voir là et si
j'appuie hop là directement j'en viens
dans des paramètres ici bon voilà un
titre d'info mois premier truc qui m'a
vraiment vraiment surpris si c'est la
fluidité c'est la réactivité du bazar
c'est extrêmement réactif et en termes
de sensations et de toucher je n'avais
pas ça avant pareil au niveau des
animations alors à vous devriez pas
parce que je commence à peine et je suis
déjà paul en train de courir mais je
trouve ça quand même vachement cool donc
en terme de jeu en terme d'expérience
termes de réactivité en termes de
fluidité trouve qu'il ya un vrai cap par
rapport à plein d'autres smartphones que
je teste la fiche technique là dessus
elle ment pas c'est rapide ça répond
bien et je trouve ça super super
chouette je me suis bien marré un peu
obligée là dessus alors là je le fais
avec la main comme ça mais on peut
totalement venir branché sa manette ici
je vais imposer ça directement là et
ensuite là on est reparti comme en 40
surtout que j'ai pas réussi à map et
c'est ce bouton la voyez pour sa
viennent tourner là alors je peux être
une clichés vous le savez dites le moi
dans les commentaires parce que j'ai
toujours du comédien peu avec mon doigt
mais sinon bon ben j'ai tout ma paie
directement et pour le mapping c'est
facile on vient ici c'est un petit
bouton qui s'appelle mappage des touches
et la voyait regarder je ve lu ma paie
mais touchent directement aux bons
endroits par exemple j'appuie un endroit
up la balle a déjà été signé tout a
signé voyage permettre une autre ici et
je me dire que ça par exemple c'est ça
hop là je le prends jeu rapide su et on
en parle plus ça c'est très très cool et
ensuite je ferme ici je peux venir
continuent à jouer donc là en terme
d'expérience c'est quand même vachement
cool parce que j'ai une petite console
dans les mains c'est pas tout nouveau ça
on l'avait déjà avant on effectivement
aussi les boutons derrière mais en terme
d'expérience de guémy sans voix quand
même le smartphone un peu plus loin il
se transforme réellement aux consoles
ici donc ça c'est pour publie fois ça
très très cool on peut le faire
également pour pas notre jeu on peut
bien le faire également pour asphalt
notre call of duty pour ce que vous
voulez ça marche tout en sachant qu'ici
au niveau des aires trigger nous ont
rajouté deux interactions ça va être
presse à une leaf donc appuyé et relâché
avant que vous les recharger une arme
clac clac on prend en charge et puis
vous avez en plus la visée gyroscopique
prenez votre smartphone faire une petite
visé avec votre pote le gyroscope c'est
plutôt pas mal autre nouveauté qu'a
voulu faire un geste ils disent ok on a
un très bon smartphone au niveau du
gaming on a un smartphone qui est plutôt
cool qui va bien si et ça je suis
d'accord à le regarder mais on n'a pas
enlevé ce truc là qu'on va l'enlever
sera quand même beaucoup plus joli donc
ça c'est vrai on un smartphone qui est
très très chouette maintenant le parent
pauvre c'était un peu la photo ils sont
dit on va venir travailler alors je vais
vous montrer les restaurants quelques
instants ils nous ont fait une
configuration à trois capteurs ici votre
grand angle c'est unique 766 un peu la
caméra flagship de sony et là vous avez
également un ultra grand-angle et vous
avez également de la macro haut niveau
l'expérience logiciel bonbons on a quoi
c'est très simple avoir trouvé la photo
on va retrouver la vidéo vous avez hop
là on peut venir en 4k et mon huit cas
directement en 24 images par secondes
assez merci aux fans dragonne 8 plus
jean one vous avez tous vos paramètres
ici la garder vous venez appuyé à place
avoue le descend directement c'est
plutôt pas mal on peut faire un petit
times la leçon peut faire un ralenti
mode photo ok bien évidemment le
portrait le panorama enfin bref on
connaît un peu tout ça vous avez
également un mode nuit sous irm d'une
bonne nuit vous le prenez up l'a voulu
et c'est également si le panorama vous
en fichez vous le prenez vous le mettez
la au et si la macro c'est votre truc
vous la prenez vous la ramenez en bas on
peut dire personnaliser un peu
l'histoire on enregistre aussi très très
cool cette année asus s'est dit ok on va
faire un très gros travail au niveau de
la photo on va regarder pour améliorer
ça c'est soit un truc qui n'allait pas
bien et on nous le reprocher donc ils
ont dû mettre un meilleur capteur est
souvenu améliorer les choses je voulais
dit qu on va regarder le résultat on va
regarder si vraiment les promesses sont
là si vraiment le truc est bien alors
regardez ça c'est une photo prise en
extérieur il fait beau il fait chaud on
voit pas qu'il fait chaud mais il fait
beau et je trouve que très honnêtement
le rendu est assez aux fraises au niveau
des hautes lumières parce que autant au
niveau de l'ombre au niveau des
feuillages bon qui on se dirait mais là
déjà ça commence un peu à s'en tirent
pas bon la voyez là on voit plus rien et
le ciel la cour du ciel et et ça va pas
c'est pas beau on va continuer on passe
sur l' ultra grand-angle mêmes reproches
je pourrai mieux acceptée d'un ultra
grand-angle mais sans que le grand-angle
est vraiment aux fraises on peut venir
zoomer en x 2 on va jusqu en fuite sert
à rien d'aller trop loin quand ça ne
dérange pas ils viennent tous un petit
peu au niveau de la lgo fatalement pour
améliorer un peu plus de piquet mais
voilà alors la regarder j'ai une partie
flou là je ne sais pas pourquoi alors
est ce que nous sommes en faillite bon
bah c'est pas grave ça ne s'apprend pas
là c'est pareil je trouve que au niveau
des hautes lumières et au dossier et du
ciel ça marche pas géré le ciel n'est
pas de cette couleur là c'est pareil
c'est le même ciel et là il ya un vrai
problème au niveau de ce traitement lala
au niveau de l'image ça ça ne marche pas
mais vraiment pas du tout l'ultra grand
angle c'est pas mieux on vient en x 2
bon voilà x 8 je vous ai mis un peu de
maquereaux histoires de regarder mais
bon le général je suis jamais bien
surpris c'est jamais bien ouf c'est un
peu moins pire mais là c'est pareil avec
lumières s'il a un petit peu de mal donc
quand même un vrai problème de gestion
des hautes lumières sur ce smartphone
est même là c'est pareil regarder le
ciel là ça correspond pas du tout à la
réalité enfin si c'est pas beau espèces
de faune plus délavé donc non il ya un
traitement qui équipe a beaucoup 1 et
alors c'est que du logiciel vous me
direz ils peuvent s'améliorer se sont
mis un bon capteur mais je trouve que
derrière l'ours quoi ils ont pas le
savoir faire mais je serai vraiment
surpris soit ils sont allés trop vite
soyons pas mis les moyens j'en sais rien
mais le rendu au niveau de la photo
regarder ça bon dieu c'est aux fraises
absolu et c'est tellement dommage alors
autre que ge alors reproché c'est qu'il
ya aucune stabilisation optique haut
niveau
du capteur principal on est quand même
sur un smartphone à plus de 1000 euros
intentions sur le redis j'ai un
tremblement essentiel donc chez moi ça
tout de suite et quand ça bouge ça bouge
et ça bouge fort et c'est pas bien quoi
donc il ya un truc qui marche pas et je
trouve ça vraiment dommage caméra de ces
le fipa de
stabilisation optique bon fond
comprendrait un peu et vous allez voir
que je trouve qu'ils pareil c'est pas
mieux quoi là le problème de lumière sur
le côté et on sort moi mais tout ça
c'est cramé ou encore c'est une caméra
de cette fille là c'est carrément moi
qui suis vraiment crâne et vous bon là
ça passe ça va mais je trouve que dans
l'ensemble il fait pas le taf au niveau
de la gestion des hautes lumières il
s'en sort pas bien donc autant à asus
s'est dit on va mettre les moyens de
mettre un très bon capteur de sony le
flagship et yannick 766 c'est vrai mais
tout le traitement logiciel commun
derrière et ce qu'on en fait c'est pas
bon si vous voulez un smartphone pour
faire de bonnes photos je ne pense pas
que c'est cela qu'il vous faille la
party gaming est ok mais la photo on
passe notre chemin dommage alors ce
smartphone pour tout vous dire qu'est ce
que j'en pense moi je pense que c'est
aujourd'hui la meilleure expérience
qu'on puisse me retrouver en termes de
gaming sur smartphone j'aime beaucoup ce
que fait asus alors après il faut
vraiment aimé l'expérience il faut aimer
le design ce côté un peu très sens
fiction mais ce qui est génial c'est que
on a des accessoires un peu tous les
côtés on a différentes façons de jouer
il ya différentes façons de mettre les
choses en place on peut venir le prendre
le poser en mode stand grâce à l'aéro
active couleurs on peut prendre une
manette alain on peut le mettre dans une
manette un bref il ya plein de façons de
venir jouer avec ce smartphone on va
qu'asus continue aller plus loin
continue à mettre à jour son smartphone
très très jolie proposition capteur
d'empreintes qui marche bien bel écran
voilà il ya différentes options à
modique ces différentes options aussi au
niveau de la gestion de la batterie de
votre smartphone au niveau de l'économie
au niveau de la recharge bref moi je
trouve très typé ce smartphone très typé
ressent smartphones de gaming mais du
coup on til davantage mais quand on veut
un smartphone de guémy je trouve ça cool
je trouve ça bien je trouve beau le
modèle pro et très réussie je sois un
peu cher attention on va parler tarifs
tout de suite attention les tailles sont
là boum on y va alors on y va pour avoir
ce smartphone dans la version normale
pas le modèle pro d'accord mais le
version un peu plus standard vous avez
une version 12 plus 256 dette à 1029
euros on est au dessus des 1000 euros 16
512 1149 euros dispo à partir de fin
juillet et le modèle professionnel c'est
18 giga de ram sont pas là pour se
marrer 512 giga de stockage
1329 euros dispo mais où donc ça y est
ça fait déjà un certain tarif c'est
quand même pas rien ensuite si vous
voulez prendre la d wilkens une coque de
protection
celle-ci 39 euros on vient rajouter si
vous voulez l'aéro active couleurs ses
89 euros mais franchement si vous jouez
beaucoup vous voulez augmenter
l'expérience avec des boutons là c'est
quand même pas mal de venir ventilé
venir après ça tout ça si vous voulez la
manette c'est à dire la manette c'est
cet élément-là plus cet élément là et
cet élément là donc vous avez en gros
plusieurs façons pour venir jouer ici je
voulais monter tout à l'heure ça ça
coûte 119 euros ça augmente un peu le
prix et puis vous avez une protection
d'écran si ça vous intéresse qui est
également ici qui elle coûte 29 euros et
april existe un autre accessoire que je
n'ai pas c'est l'europe chip qui sera
branché des manette de xbox voilà à peu
l'idée mais tout ça pour vous dire que
si vous prenez votre iphone en version
douce plus de 156 5000 29 euros et que
vous rajouter tous les accessoires sera
celui pour la manette xbox vous êtes à
1305 euros parce qu'il y en a entre ça
ça et ça sent smart phone 7 à 2 176
euros d'accessoires c'est quand même pas
rien et si vous prenez le modèle pro
plus tout ça vous êtes à c'est pas rien
1600 5 euros c'est très cher quand on
vient d'acheter ce smartphone quand on
vient prendre tout accessoire c'est
qu'on veut un smartphone n'est pas qu'un
smartphone on veut une petite console de
poche avec tous les types duplex tort
que vous allez avoir donc ça c'est
vachement cool c'est une très très jolie
proposons que je trouve très cher pas
pour tout le monde attention vraiment
pour ceux qui veulent du gaming qui
veulent se faire plaisir qu'ils veulent
un très joli smartphones de gaming et
qui veulent un truc est très très bien
fait signé asus donc ça j'aime bien je
trouve très intéressant pas pour tout le
monde attention déjà joué une fois de
plus il ya le design yale tarifs il ya
tout ça mais si
le tarif si le design si tout ça ne vous
rebute pas eh bien je trouve que asus a
encore fait une très belle mise à jour
de son rock phone avec cette version si
ce qui est très très chouette super
expérience boxing très bon produit très
belle finition voilà donc si c'est un
truc qui vous botte lire dans la
description sinon eh bien ça n'était pas
fait pour vous en tout cas moi je les
aime beaucoup je suis bien amusé avec tu
beaucoup aimé l'expérience de jeu
beaucoup de fluidité et voilà donc s'il
vous fait de l'oeil et si vous avez
encore des doutes et bien vous pouvez
enlever les doutes faire péter la
tirelire biais de quoi s'amuser petit
moi ce que vous en pensez vous oui vous
derrière votre écran en bas en
commentaire est ce que se rendent phone
si ce procès le modèle pro pourrait vous
tentez qu'est ce que vous pensez des
nouveautés et notamment de cet écran en
bas et si tu pourrais vous bottez voulu
marquer bien évidemment peu retrouve
très vite on continue à parler tech
d'ici là